hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
thank you to Hampshire and now it's on
to Nevada South Carolina FBR Hawaii when
are the primaries going to stop
surprising us plus the new war weary
refugees a hundred thousand facing a
cold wintry wait
fancy predicting the results of Super
Tuesday on March 1st after this week's
surprise but no surprise in New
Hampshire it really could be anyone's
race his Trump really on the road to the
White House is 74 year old Bernie really
going to lead the Democrats New
Hampshire I want to thank you we love
you
we're gonna be back a lot we're not
gonna forget you you started it remember
you started it the government of our
great country belongs to all of the
people and not just a handful of wealthy
campaign contributors
and here's what we're gonna do now we
take this campaign to the entire country
we're going to fight for every vote in
every state I want to say I still love
New Hampshire and I always as usual
Democrat commentator Jeffrey Robinson is
standing by for us in New York and
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is in Washington
Jeffrey you first is Hillary toast no
not at all
Bernie has to win states that don't
border on his own state of Vermont and
that's not going to be quite as easy
Hillary's always figured that there was
a firewall in South Carolina because of
the Clintons relationship with the black
community and getting the black vote in
South Carolina it's not sure that Bernie
can do that he's meeting this week with
Reverend Al Sharpton to try and bolster
his his position with the black
community but it this is a crapshoot
it's anybody's game also don't forget
that Hillary has a huge lead with what's
called super-delegates Iowa and New
Hampshire only produced four percent of
the delegates and with the
super-delegates factored in
Hillary is still way ahead and still the
favorite to get the nomination
Armstrong let's bring you in from
Washington what should some of the minor
Republican candidates like say ben
Carson do now well before disclosure I
am I remained at the cursus business
manager in close advisor dr. Carson has
no intentions of dropping out the race
he never expected to do well in New
Hampshire he spent no time there his
focus is now on South Carolina where he
will be until February 21st when he
flies it no to York for a speech he
believes that he can do well in South
Carolina the voters certainly fit
professors profile evangelical it's a
very conservative state and so dr.
Carson will spend his resources there i
think chris christie has indicated that
he's headed back to New Jersey he's got
to reevaluate and start thinking about
whether he's going to drop out the race
Bush is a team has also indicated that
for the first time he's thinking about
whether it's viable or not
not about whether he's viable from here
moving for and so right now you have
really a four-man race you have Trump
you have Cruz you have Rubio and you
have still car so I'm hanging around at
four and I think this will be reflected
in the debate that's coming up in South
Carolina pretty soon I think it's a
state that's wide open I think this this
cycle is showing us that anything is
possible well let's bring in Stacy
Hilliard who's our special guest a
Republican commentator but I know you'll
talk right across the political spectrum
to us Stacey what do you think the
Republican voter should do now who
should they support I think the
Republican voters really need to start
looking at the general election who is
actually going to be electable come
November whether it's Sanders or Hillary
on the Democrat side we need to put
somebody as our nominee that is actually
going to be able to defeat her and who
would you think is best able to do that
I I'd always said Rubio I thought he's
the candidate for the time I think he's
somebody that can bring people together
but you know this is anybody's game we
still have a long time to go we're
heading into South Carolina and into
Super Tuesday where we're going to have
it wide open that anybody can come in
Kasich at and New Hampshire and I will
see what happens I think Kasich will
play well Cruz is definitely going to
play well in the south and it's really
too close to call right now
so even Super Tuesday which often sets
the direction of travel if not sets the
whole thing off often for both parties
could not really be decisive this time
around it may not be I mean
traditionally people have dropped out
after New Hampshire because of lack of
funds not lack a will and I think that
we'll see moving into South Carolina
people are going to stay and longer than
they normally would because Trump has
added a different dynamic to the field
I'm and I think if the Republicans are
smart because those mainstream and kind
of what have been dubbed establishment
Republicans they would start to really
push behind one candidate who's going to
be elected you have to remember Trump's
never polled over 31
percent which means the majority of
Republicans are supporting a more
moderate a more mainstream or more
establishment candidate so I think that
you'll see after Super Tuesday people
starting to drop out but then you have
the dynamic of potentially Bloomberg
coming in I'm and he's been saying that
he's going to see what happens at the
end of March I think we should talk
about in a minute but let me just pitch
it back to Jeffrey and Armstrong here
let me get you to talk about the other
side if I may Jeffrey if you were a
Republican strategist what would you be
thinking right now well I was on Monday
I was in Miami speaking to a major Jeb
Bush backer and strategist I mean I'm
talking about us a really major guy
who's been with the Bush family for many
many years go all the way back to George
senior and he tells me that Jeb is a
strategy the strategy now is to amass as
many delegates as possible between he
and Kasich and Christie and they're
going to try and keep Christie in the
race to nullify Rubio to get as many
delegates as possible to deny Donald
Trump the automatic crowning of the
nomination at the convention in July
in other words Jeb Bush is now playing
for a brokered convention and they are
also planning at the moment to hijack
that convention so that Bush will secure
the nomination and bring cases along on
the ticket as vice president now that's
a very dangerous game to play because it
puts all of the chips on one roll of the
dice if if if he can pull it off and get
the nomination that's one thing if not
and Bloomberg comes in it's a whole
different game but even if Jeb Bush
manages to hijack the convention and
secure the nomination if Donald Trump
goes to Cleveland in July with the
largest selection of delegates he's not
going to be pleased and he will form a
third party and completely sink the
Republicans well Armstrong that would be
as Jeffrey says yes an extraordinary
strategy wouldn't it because the sort of
anti-establishment anti existing
politics candidate is going to get
trumped quite literally by the
establishment the regular guys ganging
up on him at the convention you know
this is really complicated we we don't
have much precedent
for this and there's a lot of guessing
what you think could possibly happened
Donald Trump is such a wild card even if
you sit down and negotiate with him and
you come to some understanding going
forward I don't know what the deal holds
up not you have Jeb Bush and in New
Hampshire calling him a liar
and that's just a whole different ball
game they really just just despise him
they just have total disdain for them I
don't know what they can galvanize
around someone like a Trump I just don't
know and then many of them don't believe
that he's a true conservative that he
really holds the values of the
Republican Party whether a candidate can
rise to - to Trump Trump I don't know if
that's possible I think the best
strategy if the Republicans really have
any shot at winning the White House is
the rally around the candidate that is
gaining the steam in the minute but the
momentum that the American people
specially Republican base shows a lot of
faith in and try to arm mr. Trump with
the kind of Polish and the kind of
temperament that is necessary to be the
kind of candidate that could defeat a
Hillary Clinton if she's the nominee and
I was gonna ask you I'm started to chip
in about the Democrats as well if you
were a say a Hillary strategist what
would you be thinking right now well you
know she really doesn't have much to
concern herself with because um Bernie
Sanders as Jeffrey said would do well in
a place like New Hampshire esada New
Hampshire mrs. Clinton still dominates
across the board she will do well I
think Bernie Sanders is a very decent
guy he's bringing a level of
conversation to the dialogue about Wall
Street and about Millennials were not
represented in this process but other
than that it would be I don't see a
scenario where it's it's remotely
possible for Bernie Sanders to defeat
her and I think she knows this very well
and I think that New Hampshire is behind
her she should March pretty smoothly the
rest of the way
Stacy let's bring you back in here the
nature of this year's fight is
extraordinarily vicious I mean it's
always a little bit alien to our UK
sentiments where politics isn't quite so
personal even at its worst but this time
around
how can a candidate really emerge with
any credibility
when so much has been said about them
and their peers over these last few
months I think we saw this in New
Hampshire which is why Kasich did so
well and why Bernie did so well they
rose above the politics above the
name-calling and above the mudslinging
and they have been running a very
positive campaign and when you speak to
voters in New Hampshire that was
something that really appealed to them
I'm but I just want to comment on this
issue about Hillary having nothing to
worry about
I think Hillary has a lot to worry about
she's been in this position before she's
been the favorite and she lost to
someone who was an idealist and who was
seen as a outsider and that's who our
president is now and she lost to him so
I think she has a lot to to worry about
the polling numbers people don't trust
her people don't believe that she's
believable that she cares about them
that she's going to do things and their
interests they believe she's only doing
things in her interest which is why you
have this swell of support behind Bernie
and he's flooding into South Carolina
with workers staffers volunteers I think
you're going to be surprised we
shouldn't underestimate him and on the
Republican side the best debate we had
was the one without Trump where the
candidates were actually able to talk
about policy and not have to deflect
insults and can I just pick you up on
something you mentioned the Bloomberg
factor which is another delicious
unknown in all this and yet I'm told he
may be well known to us here in the UK
he may be well known to the eastern
seaboard of the states but is he really
got much clout in California in Nevada
or you know in the north he is well
known he's known across the country I
people are really wanting him to come in
I think he will struggle in some really
strong red states I for some of his
policies that he's put in in New York
he'll be seen as a bit of a liberal but
if it's Trump Sanders
I think Bloomberg stands a very good
chance and it's a no brainer for him to
get in if it's Sanders and another
Republican I think he will probably not
come in Jeffrey would you put some money
on Michael Bloomberg as an outside shot
yeah you
I think the only thing that keeps him
out is the nomination of Hillary I think
if it's Sanders he comes in no matter
who the Republicans put up but an
interesting statistic does get thrown up
after New Hampshire no Republican
candidate who has achieved the
nomination has ever done so without
winning Iowa or New Hampshire and South
Carolina has in the last I forget how
many cycles but many always picked the
winner
so if Trump and he's way ahead in South
Carolina equally ahead in South Carolina
as he was in New Hampshire if Trump wins
South Carolina then the oddsmakers have
to say look he's following in the
tradition of all of the other Republican
nominees for the presidency and could
win it I'm strong Michael Bloomberg sort
of half Republic isn't he could you
support him well you know as someone who
was a broadcaster I don't state my
opinion oh those kind of issues even
though I do support my friend dr. ben
Carson but generally I don't want to get
into that I have a lot of respect for
mr. Bloomberg and I've interviewed him
and I think he would add an interesting
dynamic you know I have to tell you this
I and I hear what I guess is saying
about mrs. Clinton and I hope she's
challenged and I hope she's correct but
I don't think that the the the map of
the voters to play out and Bernie
Sanders favored and more than that I I
think it's gonna be very difficult for
the establishment anybody to stop mr.
Trump he's way ahead and my native home
state of South Carolina he will do place
well in places like Nevada he will do
very well in very places like the South
they lacked that rim meet they like that
meet about keep the Muslims out even his
vulgar language that people call vulgar
people in South would not see this
vulgar that's the way to communicate
with each other they take him as being
serious as being tough and I think we've
seen the worst that he probably could
give us as a candidate and if he ever
gets on his best behavior which he's
shown signs of it especially if you look
at Iowa the way he eventually
congratulated and conceded to take Cruz
but he changed that within hours if he's
able to be get his temperament under
control to really save something for a
change where people really know what he
believes because I don't think anyone
really knows what Trump believes and how
you were governed I think it's gonna be
very difficult to stop the steamroller
that you may see going forward and
Stacey just a final thought to you on
the man you said was your favorite you
used the past-tense
Marco Rubio the photogenic guy is
clearly a lead for many what went wrong
there
can you ever come back I think he can he
has to readjust reassess some things I
think he jumped a little too early on
thinking it was a general camp a general
election campaign in New Hampshire in
the debate and I think if he and the
other candidates are actually able to
hold Trump to account to say how are you
going to do this how are you going to
stop Isis how are you going to create
jobs give us a plan kind of do the
kamikaze type debate that Christie did
with Rubio in New Hampshire I think he
can still stand a chance because I was
just home at Christmas and my home state
of Texas and where my family is in
Memphis and I haven't found a trump
supporter I found people who say you
know sometimes he does make a little bit
of sense but I could never support him
and they're supporting Cruz Rubio and
Kasich Stacey Hilliard good to have you
with us today thank you thank you you
can catch up with Sky News debate on
Apple TV Roku and ketchup and of course
on Sky News com / us the Syrian conflict
is becoming even more complex the exodus
is worsening since the fighting started
five years ago more than half of the
people there have been forced to leave
their homes last month the United
Nations said that 13 and a half million
people out of a pre-conflict population
of 23 million have been displaced
well let's cross now to Gaza and type in
turkey close to the Syrian border
Dalia a lark RT is the director of
programs in North Syria for Mercy Corps
the largest aid organization working in
Syria after the United Nations and Dalia
I imagine conditions are pretty tough
just describe what you're trying to do
absolutely well the conditions right now
are definitely difficult for our staff
and
partners on the ground mercy port is the
second largest provider of humanitarian
assistance in North Syria serving an
estimated 500,000 people a month so a
lot of people depend on us to get
assistance and of course and to make
sure that they are able to meet their
basic needs the situation over the past
several days that was continuously
deteriorating a lot of people have had
to leave their homes in search of safety
with actually a large population still
in the city now waiting to see what the
fate of their city is tell me about the
logistics how are you able to move
supplies around the country or get
supplies into the country given the fact
that most of Syria's our war zone well
it's actually a process it's a very
time-consuming process of course we're
able to transport supplies into North
Syria across two routes one route goes
through northern Syria through Aleppo
Governorate and it's that same route
that's now been cut into Alamo City so
that was our easiest most direct route
into new Aleppo City and we use it to
provide assistance in northern Ural
Aleppo and then again partially in the
city then on the other side we are able
to go through a relatively western route
through a clip governor it and that were
just doing usable of course for an oppo
City but it's a very risky Road Road
with a lower capacity and it's been very
unreliable in the past it's it hosts
quite a few skirmishes really so every a
day every day or two over the past few
months it's actually been where we
haven't be able to transport goods
because it's been under sniper fire it's
been under attack by different armed
factions so very risky routes route that
comes at a very heavy cost to our staff
of course and our team well let's just
bring in Jeffrey Robinson in New York
and Armstrong Williams in Washington
Armstrong it strikes me it's pretty
humbling governments around the world
have failed to find any kind of solution
or humanitarian solution for this
particular crisis it's been going for
five years
yet these people are committed to
risking their lives to trying to feed
their fellow man you know Martin you
really have to in sort of a
contemplative way consider both sides I
mean I think Sween is an example of a
government that was once rich and
resources who tried to do the benevolent
and the compassionate thing because they
felt deeply for these people that they
needed a place a refuge and yet they
started out with a small number of
refugees to bring in and then increase
those numbers and all of a sudden 35,000
was dropped on the country and they
could not handle it economically they
could not hear me
they don't have corporations that pay
for it it's bankrupting the country they
can't take him anymore if you take a
place like Sweden Sweden is sort of an
example I want other countries to face
and you know and then you give the false
hope to these refugees that they leave
their homeland and they can find a
better way of life you got babies you
got the elderly
you've got the indigent and you mix it
all these people together yet you get
please need some of these sounds
sometimes when you get these refugees in
places like a place like Germany their
values clash their rates
there's Erasmus there's crime and you
mix all these things and it shows you
that this process was not well thought
through and not only has the government
become victim in trying to help the
refugees that you're trying to rescue
are even more victims than they were
before and until someone gets a handler
around this situation they consider the
consequences and whether you want to
build sanctuary cities in these areas
where these people are they try to take
care them so you can use the rest
resources wisely not much is going to
change its gonna go worse Geoffrey the
West in particular and the Americans
specifically do have a responsibility
here don't they because I think it's
widely accepted they were sort of
interfering in the conflict by trying to
support some Syrian opposition five
years ago when this all started and yet
it did send it into a complete mess is
there not a legacy responsibility there
we all have a responsibility I mean the
the sheer callousness that we are
demonstrating in the West towards a
humanitarian problem of enormous tragedy
I mean thirteen and a half million
people throughout
their own country and as Armstrong said
the indention the indigent grandparents
children parents I mean it is just
horrifying how we in the West and all
over the West say oh yeah we want to we
want to help and give lip service but
not in my backyard it I just don't know
that there is an answer I think though
there is another problem which is going
to make this even worse and and I want
to get into this very simply to say oil
the price of oil has been coming down
we're at what twenty dollars a barrel is
something like that predictions are that
it could go as low as ten now that will
bankrupt ISIL because they won't be able
to earn the kind of money that they were
earning at forty and fifty and sixty
dollars a barrel but it's also going to
bankrupt Russia and that presents a huge
problem to mr. Putin and what leaders
traditionally do when they are trouble
in trouble economically at home is turn
to foreign policy and look for some sort
of a major headline in foreign policy he
will do that in Syria we need to get rid
of my son he wants to keep us on and as
long as he's dead looking for headlines
to save his ass at home the situation is
going to get much much much worse than
it is
just tragic and Dalia that's a that's a
terrible prospect isn't it that these
global forces of countries and
allegiances around the globe are
fighting one another and a disagreeing
while another and you're dealing with
the real consequences of everyday
survival well it's a that's that's
absolutely the biggest tool on the
Syrian conflict has been on civilians
and while there's a core and other
actors provide humanitarian assistance
it does not replace the need for a
political solution a political solution
really is the only end to the suffering
of Syrians how do you operate and who do
you decide to help because you don't
know who your friend is or who your
enemy is at this stage do you know where
humanitarian agencies so we we started
operating in Syria well over three years
ago almost four years now and so at the
very beginning of the crisis were able
to get in and actually start supporting
communities and people that were in need
of assistance people that no longer had
access to subsidized resources people
that no longer had access to basic food
items and other basic items so we
worried that we were the first actor on
the field we were the Mersey poverty was
the first to show up in Syria and say
we're here to help and that's really
gained us a lot of credibility and has
maintained our strong reputation both
inside Syria and outside especially with
the families and the communities that we
work with which are essentially the most
integral parts of our work we don't pick
who we work with outside of people in
need so we deal with people who are in
meat we work with those people to
provide assistance that they now depend
on for meeting their basic needs their
day-to-day needs and working based on a
principle of humanitarian neutrality a
very core concept to our work is really
what enables us to be the largest
operator in North Syria and what about
your funding because presumably what you
do is costs money oh absolutely we have
different funding streams and we have
over the past few years but we just get
a lot of money from well quite a bit of
money from different donors and
particularly for North Syria we are
funded by the US donors and also by UK
donors Dalia thank you very much indeed
Geoffrey Armstrong good to see you again
thank you and thank you for watching
that's it for this edition of the debate
you can continue watching Sky News on
Apple TV Roku and catch up and of course
at Sky News calm until next time goodbye